[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
be a subscriber like and comment
the last giveaway winners are hey guys
in this video we are going to talk about
main characters who are most definitely
going to die in the next and final
episode
starting with Danny general killer in
the finale that's now a certain thing
then it became the meth Queen much to my
disappointment especially because there
was no real build-up for this moment and
John will have to stop her what Dana
just did in episode 5 is what her father
wanted to do before Jim stopped him burn
everything and everyone down in King's
Landing then it did not have any reason
whatsoever to burn down the capital the
bells rang enemy army surrendered and
all she had to do was March her armies
on the red cape kill Cersei and take the
city without any killing simple as that
however Dany decided to unleash foreign
blood and kill all the innocent people
her arm is full of her lead and started
slaughtering all the women and children
except for John who tried to prevent
unnecessary killing which is personally
my best moment from this very bad
episode
Daniel's after all the meth Queen and I
guess the final villain odd story as I
said in my episode 6 trailer breakdown
video I did / dated an Indian salad
would go nuts and I even said that Danny
burning the red cape would be justified
and it would not make her the mad queen
just like he did not make other
Targaryen before when they use dragons
to burn down castles and their enemies
we all expected Danny to go and kill
Cersei by burning down the red cape but
known red cape was the last thing she
burned down
she only been to attack the red cape
after she was done with burning the
entire city 3 by Street building by
building she spent almost the entire
episode burning it down along with all
the innocent people look at a shot of
all deposits of all four exploding as
Geoghan breeds fire and destruction
through King's Landing
there's no excuse for any of this and
then he should never have done this and
as much as I like Danny or at least I
did until the infamous taped episode
then he has to die now and John knows it
perhaps that's why he was resurrected to
stop they indeed met Queen in the final
episode we have a shot of John and I was
walking through the streets of King's
Landing or seeing all the horrors Danny
did and I think it's here that John
realizes Varys was right after all the
coin did not land well for Danny in fact
I think John already
grated not listening to eros in Episode
five when she started her burning the
innocent free it's funny that fairies
died for the same reason Ned Stark did
for supporting the rightful heir to the
Iron Throne and not bowing to the false
kings and queens very similar old
letters to each and every Kingdom
informing all the lords and ladies who
true heir of the Iron Throne is much
like Ned Stark did in the first season
when Joffrey took the throne net wrote
letters and send it to other Lords how
Joffrey is not the true heir
but it's Dennis I read many comments of
people saying that Varys did not send
those letters told important people as
just before he was arrested he was seen
burning a letter this is not true
yes first did burn the last scroll but
he already sent a bunch of letters at
this point Maris was writing those
letters all day and it was not until the
night that he was arrested every Lord
across Westeros received theirs his
message regarding who the true heir is
and who they should support I think in
the next episode the already mentioned
new Prince of Dorne as well as all other
important lords and ladies from Robin
Arryn - er Greyjoy all will show up at
King's Landing some to support John's
claim some to support Danny's cause the
season a leagues already confirmed that
his Dornish Prince would appear in the
final episode as an actor Toby Osman was
casted for this role Toby's character
will very cold enough it just like
Auburn did and he will likely commit all
the Dornish forces however I do not
believe there will be a war between John
and Danny since John does really want
the Iron Throne nevertheless John will
kill Danny after what she's done in
King's Landing and after a bit
convincing from Tyrion to do it that's
Danny's betrayal for love and that's
kind of this show of lend the show
unfortunately made dana demouth queen
and they did it in one single episode
various did one john that he thinks
Danny is going mad and John saw it for
himself in the Battle of King's Landing
Tyrion will probably say the same thing
to John in the next episode convincing
John that he's the only one able to stop
her Tyrion will also tell to John about
the conversation he had with Daniel
chicken stone in the beginning of
episode 5 the one about Sansa and how
Danny Caesar is a traitor into one
plotting to overthrow her in her mind
says says the reason Vera's betrayed her
and she's reason her claim is threatened
Tyrion will tell John about this
conversation and he will tell him how
Danny sees sense as a threat and he just
witnessed how Danny deals with those
threats the same Baker fathered the Mad
King dead by burning them alive along
with old innocent to be fair John
already saw for himself that Danny must
be stopped now that she's killed a
couple of hundreds of thousands of
innocent small folk John tried to stop
his armies from killing enemy armies
John killed his own men who tried to
force himself on an innocent girl during
the battle King's Landing how do you
think he'll react to affect that Dany
just burned entire King's Landing in the
water armies to brutally slain women and
children it's funny that when you think
about it all the villains we head
through the story from Joffrey to Cersei
Remzi in the night King all them
together did not kill as many innocent
people as Danny did in just one episode
Kings landings got a population of 1
million people if not the vast majority
of this number then at least the chef
Danny just burned alive John already
knows that he's got to stop Danny enter
no telling how Danny sees her family
especially since as traitors her
plotting behind her back John will only
become means that he's got to do it that
he's got to stop Danny's madness no
matter the cost no matter the fact that
she's a woman he loves from the preview
we know that after this I don't know if
we can even call it a victory then he
will walk out to the red cape to give
her armies some kind of a speech I guess
at least that's what it seems is going
on here she'll probably talk about how
they just removed one tyrant
which is kind of funny considering she's
far worse than Cersei ever was after
this I expect John to walk up inside red
cape inside this Droid throne room only
to see Danny probably sitting on the
Iron Throne and basically being the
queen of the ashes let the only brains
vision from the future that is yet to be
seen on screen the destroyed throne room
covered in ashes
let me remind you that while prophecies
in Game of Thrones don't really come
true visions on the other hand do all
brands visions already came true
including vault fire tech search they
used on Sept of Baelor and a vision of a
shadow flying about the capital that
came through in the last episode
not only did bran had this vision and
therefore we know this scene will be
included in the final episode but then
he also had similar vision back in
season 2 then he had a vision that she
was in the iron throne room but
everything was destroyed in the ground
Oscar
in snow or so he thought now that the
night king is dead and Danny burned down
his landing to the ground the snow
ending his vision was actually ash
anyways Kauai siege on killing Daniel's
like this he already knows Danny's her
father's daughter
the meth queen and he has to stop her
Tyrion will also tell Jon how Danny sees
his family as a huge threat and traders
who are conspiring against her and
therefore Danny will probably kill them
as soon as she gets the chance much like
she did Varys Jen knows he's got to do
something but I believe that before he
does he will give the any violence
chance trying to talk with her to see if
she realizes what she's done is a huge
mistake in crime Danny will then
probably justify her actions and that's
when John will realize there's no
turning back
she's this mad queen and a huge threat
to Westeros having already destroyed one
great city in hundreds of thousands of
innocent people and John Alden killer I
believe that's what Dan his vision from
the undying was were sharing all along
then he wins the Iron Throne and becomes
queen of ashes that are covering it but
she will not be able to ever sit on it
or least not for long because John will
have to put an end to her madness
whereupon she'll join Drago and her son
on the other world after that John will
probably take the black again for
killing Danny and go back to the wall
and become thousands Lord Commander the
Nights Watch living out his days in the
real north and reuniting with ghost a
storm foreshadowed then it will not be
the only one dying in the Game of
Thrones finale Tyrion will die as well
throughout the fifth episode Tyrion is
appropriately shocked by Danny's actions
that is not how he wanted it to go down
and this is not the Queen he knows and
supports in episode 16 is obviously AB
savvy Danny I believe he will throw his
kind of the kingpin after this and
Tyrion will die ending House Lannister
then it did burn tyrion early on in
episode 5 that if he fails her again it
will be his last
and what was through his next action in
that episode failing Dany and releasing
Jaime from prison and not only did he
free Jaime but he also made it clear
that it was him who did it Tyrion did a
good job identifying himself to the
unsullied guards saying that he is the
hand of the Queen and he commands him to
have a word with the prisoner whereupon
he is set him free
from the episode six trailer we can tell
Tyrion is destroyed not only because of
a fact that his siblings Jaime
sir-sir dead but also by the fact that
Danny his screen and the one he betrayed
varies for and the one he fought for has
done all these horrors to King's Landing
what's especially heartbreaking to me
it's seeing Tyrion walking through the
ruins of the Capitol heading straight
towards Danny even though he knows he
will be executed for freeing Jaime and
trying to have Jaime escort Cersei to
safety but this point Tyrion doesn't
really care for his life he has just
witnessed his family collapse and his
Queen burned down all the innocent he is
destroyed to say at the very least
Tyrion will be executed for failing
Danny again but the lowest of the
Lannisters actually is the highest of
the Lannister now will not down just
like that
he will secure Danny goes down as well I
believe during his time in dungeons
Tyrion will ask John to come and visit
him which is when the earlier mentioned
conversation between John and Tyrion
will take place Tyrion will reveal to
him Danny's feelings towards the Starks
whom she now sees as traitors led by
Sansa and dedicated to end her reign as
I already said this'll only further
John's believe that Danny must be
stopped and that the bittersweet ending
will get and that's how Game of Thrones
will end with Jon killing Danny never in
the seven hells did I assume Danny would
be the final villain of the story but
here we are
anyways please let me know your thoughts
about all of this in the comment section
down below and stay tuned for many
videos they're yet to come and as always
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace